you just heard vice president mike pants
tell us that every state has the ability
to conduct coronavirus tests but reports
say the test shortage is still a major
obstacle to containing the virus our dr.
David agus joins us from Los Angeles
once again doctor good morning you heard
what the Vice President had to say
what's your response
a couple things one is having the
ability to do tests and actually having
you know doing the tests and having the
administrative ability to actually get
people their tests them give them
results or separate things the shocking
thing to me is is that overnight he
could say no travel from Europe and it's
gonna stop as of midnight tonight yet he
still can't get the 50 states in the
United States to give him the data on
what testing has happened and what are
the results of those tests that just
didn't seem right to me dr. agus we know
now the NBA has canceled its season
early I can't suspend it the rest of its
season number of cities have canceled
events I know that you have helped to
make some of those decisions what goes
into them they're critical decisions and
obviously it makes a lot of people
unhappy because these are events that
people have looked forward to for a long
period of time but you have to look at
the infrastructure medical in the city
if there are more illnesses can it
handle it are the hospital's full are
the emergency rooms full what is the
demographic of the city and how many
numbers of cases are there and what
we're seeing now is that it's just going
more and more across the board you know
for a while it was the Centers of high
numbers of cases it was Seattle it was
the San Francisco area it was New York
and now we're seeing more and more
literally across the country because we
have to stop spread of this virus is it
what you public health methods work
David is that what you mean when you say
you want to flatten the curve of the
rate of spreading of the virus exactly
Anthony is that you know if the virus
happens all at once there's a big peak
there what's gonna happen is our medical
infrastructure is overwhelmed and many
deaths will happen that don't need to
happen if we can slow the onset of the
virus we can actually handle it with the
medical infrastructure in the United
States and the drugs that are in
development now will hopefully happen
all right clear concise messaging dr.
David Angus thank you we'll be right
back